the other day I got to thinking about
card games and I'm not quite sure why
what jogged my memory but it's something
that I in the course of my life and
particularly my childhood and my teens
and 20s spent a lot of time
engaged in in a lot of different modes
you could say sometimes it was a matter
of finding a way to kill time or pass
time you know it's a way to escape
boredom to engage your mind with
something a lot of times it was a way to
have fun with people that I was friends
with or family with or connected to in
some other way and the card games
themselves could be uh you could say a
means for enjoying the company of others
sometimes it was about the challenge of
the game itself or its intrinsic
interestingness you could say at times I
could get competitive about it as well
I'm not a big Gambler uh you know I I
have played some games of chance for for
money from time to time as I'll tell you
in a moment but the competitive aspect
was very often more in terms of bragging
rights or
um you know the the sheer uh involvement
with somebody else who's playing against
you or a whole bunch of people that are
playing against you so I'm going to tell
the story here of the different games
that I've played perhaps you've played
some of these maybe some of them are
completely unfamiliar to you
but I think that it could be of some
interest to others and I do want to say
this that the
playing of the card games
is in many respects a function of having
grown up in an era before the internet
and before the you know instantaneous
updating of information when life was I
don't want to say necessarily a little
slower but there was more space in it
for the kinds of things that would be
just casual card games and
that may not be quite so easy or readily
available to those who've grown up you
know in the last several decades so let
me start at the uh beginning with my
childhood so you know as a kid in the
kind of household that I grew up in in
the neighborhood I grew up in with the
kind of friends that I had there were a
lot of card games that you just kind of
learned right and some of them are
indeed childhood games like Go Fish and
um
you know these are kind of like matching
games but one though he played a lot was
war
and War
can be done with two people it can be
done with three people it can actually
be done with four people and you're
always trying to like turn over cards
and get the highest card whoever gets
the highest card gets to take the trick
and then put it at the bottom of their
stack and it goes for a while you know
and it's it's kind of a fun game and if
you have ties then you have to like you
you add some extra stuff to it you could
say so he played a lot of that
we also played a lot of Spades a lot of
hurts these are trick taking games of
different sorts that I haven't played
for a very long time
there was another one that was called
Rook that was kind of popular in the 70s
and it had its own deck I had a hard
time finding people to play that with me
other than in my family and that one
kind of died out and then there were the
first the precursor was Crazy Eights
right uh the game where you're trying to
go out and then there was one that
became really big and had its own deck
with a couple interesting twists and
teasers in there like you know draw two
or change the color and it was called
Uno and boy did a lot of people enjoy
playing that my mom got really into it
my grandma got into it we would uh have
an Uno deck most of the time when we
were like going camping or something
along those lines and it was very easy
for children to learn I think rather
intuitive and so that was that was an
easy one to play but the one that we
probably played the most when I was a
kid was rummy and it typically was rummy
500.
um and you know it's a pretty
straightforward game there's you know
all sorts of variations on rummy
um I'll tell you about Michigan Romney
in a bit and there's also gin rummy
which I played for a little while but
Rummy 500 is one where you're
essentially you know forming runs and uh
Triplets of things and you keep scoring
when you get to 500 somebody's won and
and that's basically all there is to the
game but it's very versatile and you can
play it over and over and over again and
it's quite fun sometimes you pick up a
lot of cards and you know that can be a
little dangerous for you to do so people
oh you took you know 10 cards right and
uh it's you know it's a fun game it's
one of the few games that I still play
in the present my my wife and I have
started doing it in the last year and
it's you know it's good it's training
for the mind and keeps you sharp and
it's easy to do and you can take the
deck anywhere you want and and play it
now things kind of changed for me the
year that my dad got sick and died and
the reason that that was the case was
my grandfather and grandmother first
came to stay with us at our our house
you know on the border of Wales and
Delafield my grandfather Sadler my dad's
dad was you know living with us as well
but he was you know pretty
he was not very helpful right I mean he
burned pizzas he'd drink all the time
and stuff like that Grant grandpa and
grandma lamris on the other hand were
you know my mom's uh Mom and Dad they
were able to help us out while my mom
was with my dad in Minnesota at the Mayo
Clinic where he he was for about three
months before he he actually passed away
um and so you know we we wound up
learning to play games and it was more
me than my sister
um my grandma decided that you know I
was 11 years old it was time for me to
learn one of the games that I saw people
playing in the family all the time
pinochle now pinochle is sort of like
some of these other trick games you know
like Spades or Hearts but it's got its
own kind of deck it's kind of
complicated it's got you know you got to
declare Trump and you do bidding and
stuff like that so I was like growing up
into real card games you could say right
and so for my grandma I learned pinochle
and then for my grandpa I learned
another card game that members of my
family played as well cribbage cribbage
is played on this board with pegs and
you you move them to count your points
and you know there's various ways to
play it you can play two-handed
three-handed four-handed five-handed you
know there's all different interesting
variations and it was something that a
lot of the adults in my family did so
let me go on a brief
discursis about that
pinochle was a game that pretty much
everybody who is an adult in my family
my branch of the lemuries family so
we're counting my grandpa my grandma
also my uncle Hubert and Aunt Therese
who are Grandpa and Grandma's brothers
and sisters Two Brothers married two
sisters and lived next door to them and
then you know my Aunt Mary my aunt bib
Uncle Scott Uncle aim and then Uncle
Scott's mom and dads the ectorlings
father art who's my grandpa's brother
they all played that my mom would play
as well so you could you could pretty
much count on being able to get into a
Pinochle game pretty easily and very
often they'd be played in my uh you know
Uncle Hubert's basement on this big
wooden table where we often did a lot of
things we spent a lot of time down there
and it was such a cool game you know so
getting to like sit at the table and
start to play and we played all sorts
you know you could play two-handed like
my grandma taught me to play there was
three-handed which now it starts to get
a little bit more complicated and then
the real fun ones four-handed with
partners
and
um
uh five-handed
six-handed up to eight-handed where you
actually use three decks I should
mention too my aunt honey Therese
Grandma's sister played and she was very
aggressive Uncle Hubert was one of the
only older people who didn't play he
preferred to go off and read books
instead but everybody else would and it
was it was a lot of fun and it was you
know really great sort of training for
the the mind and you know thinking about
how to set things up and you learn how
to estimate what you're going to make in
terms of points and learn how to work
with your partner or against Partners or
whatever else you were doing so it was
really quite cool cribbage on the other
hand the people who played that my dad
had played it a lot but of course he was
dying Grandpa uh Uncle uh Uncle aim Aunt
Mary Uncle Scott uh and then
occasionally other people would play it
as well father art would play and those
were the main people so you know there
are several different cribbage boards
there was like a two-handed one a
three-handed one a four-handed one and
we would often you know and when we had
some spare time like waiting for dinner
or something like that or just killing
some time during the day we'd get out
the cribbage board and we'd play
and again
it exercises certain parts of your mind
that I think are you know quite quite
good now I never did find other people
to play pinochle with except maybe one
time in the army cribbage was something
that I could play with people all over
because it's a little bit more common
and I have indeed played with quite a
few people who aren't my family
um
in eighth grade so that would have been
like the summer learning these two games
had been the summer between sixth and
seventh grade in eighth grade we've read
a really interesting book and I don't
remember the name of it all I really
remember it was a book about baseball
players and sort of like not major
league but the thing below it and their
lifestyle and one of the things that
they would do they played this legendary
card game essentially to like initiate
and fleece money out of their friends uh
the new people called tegwar the
exciting game without any rules
and you could make it be anything that
you wanted and I found this idea
absolutely fascinating much much much
later my wife and I when we were in our
early flirtation phase you could call it
we uh played a a variant of tag War
without cards but doing other things
because it's adaptable coming back to uh
cards
um you know I did also learn to play
gambling games
um occasionally we would play poker for
pennies and nickels and stuff like that
you learn different variations of Poker
I was never really a big Gambler in part
because usually I don't make money when
I do that and I find that rather
frustrating and but you know playing
poker could be fun for for a while
provided that people don't take it too
seriously because when people can get
very worked up about it I also enjoyed
playing Blackjack and we would often and
at Uncle John and Aunt Mary's Place the
cards would come out we'd get out you
know pennies and nickels and dimes and
play for small sums and somebody would
be the dealer and and we would play
Blackjack together my Aunt Mary is
actually a very big and good Gambler
herself
and so you know we played those but then
there was another game I mentioned
Michigan rummy and this is played on
kind of a board that's got like uh
different spots for it I don't remember
exactly how it's played but there's
money to be made or lost in the game and
it's got some connections with Rummy 500
but also with other things as well and
we used to play that quite a lot I
remember as as a kid in my childhood and
then my my teens as well
but one of the games that uh became a
big thing for me in college and it
didn't take too long for me to learn is
called sheep's head
there's not a lot of people who play it
outside of Wisconsin it's also called
shops cough right which is German for
sheep's head and I think some people
play it in in Germany and other
german-speaking places
and it's a complicated game it's sort of
like pinochle except imagine if like you
took pinochle and turned it on its side
and gave it a couple quick punches to
deform it well that is what sheep said
is like there's all these complicated
you know rules and and Trump you know is
set up in kind of a weird way unlike
pinochle where any suit can be you know
Trump it's it's actually fixed and it's
not just the diamonds it's also you know
uh the kings and queen or the the
Jackson queens and I don't quite
remember I'd have to brush up on how to
play it if I did it again but I found
this game fun as hell and it's probably
connected to the fact that I was having
a great time in college I'll tell you
kind of a crazy story about sheep's head
so when I was in my freshman year of
college they had these uh Suites so
there was a dorm and you know in in this
instead of having like you know just a
big dorm thing with a room and you'd
have the roommate you'd have your own
individual room and there would be four
of them in a suite and then like a
shared bathroom
and they had taken some of these sweets
and they converted them into what they
called language Suites so they're trying
a new pilot program you would take some
of the language classes there would be a
native speaker of that language there
and
um you know you were supposed to be it
was supposed to be like an immersive
experience so I got put into the French
language Suite because they knew that I
spoke some French and there were two
other guys uh in it a guy named Zhu
um who was hmong and who spoke a bit of
French and then there was Dan who was
supposed to be learning French but
always had a terrible accent and didn't
didn't really know that much and then
there was our so you know our teacher
and person in charge Cecile revoltisol
who is you know probably in her mid-20s
or so which seemed very old to us at the
time and uh you know
I don't think took her duties all that
seriously she's like drinking with us
and hanging out and stuff like that
eventually Zhu left and uh this girl
Faith moved in who actually had no
intention of learning the language
whatsoever and so there was a French
Suite a Spanish sweet
a German sweet and then a Japanese sweet
and in the Japanese Suite there was an
old guy and I don't remember his name
but the poor guy didn't know what he got
himself in for and then the other three
people there was Dave who was like a you
know kind of computer geek and you know
D and D nerd and stuff like that and uh
also into metal and you know he and I
made friends right away then there was
uh Taco uh which is the you know what he
went by his name was actually Chris he
was an older guy in one of the frats
loved to party he would actually end up
moving off campus later on and he was
always kind of struggling with stuff but
he was a great person to know for like
where the parties were going to be and
then there was Larry and Larry was a
townie he was from you know Sheboygan
um his mom actually worked at the school
and he eventually you know he ended up
dropping out
um maybe you know with a lot of college
students they're not really ready to go
to college and so nobody moved into his
room
now that set up an interesting
opportunity
that room became known as the party room
so
you know three or four nights a week
after all of our stuff was finished
probably starting around like eight
o'clock or nine o'clock somebody would
buy a case of beer and we had a table
set up in there and we'd come down with
our nickels and dimes and quarters and
stuff like that
and we would play sheep set and you know
play music and so we were partying but
the partying was you know we were
getting drunk of course but it was
mostly I was smoke up a storm too
because everything was was a lot you
could smoke back then
um was playing Sheepshead and getting
excited about that and uh talking about
it and the poor Japanese guy at the end
of the hall you know he was so polite
and we probably made life kind of rough
for him as a bunch of Rowdy college
students and you know the only thing
that actually kind of pulled me out of
there because my grades were fine I was
getting my work done I was actually also
um helping out with the soccer team
doing some training and stuff like that
you know I could I could afford to like
screw off four nights a week in a place
where we could party cheap and have a
lot of fun playing this cards game
um I wound up you know uh having a
girlfriend and then you know she wasn't
keen on me spending so much time with
the guys doing that but boy was that a
lot of fun and you know we would I would
also play sheep's head with my my friend
Marshall who unfortunately died quite
quite young but you know with his
parents and you know my friend Ed and
all these other people so sheep said I
have a lot of good memories about that
um I did also learn Euchre which is
another trick game never was big on
euchre if you've played pinochle or
sheep's head Euchre seems kind of pale
in comparison you don't get as many
cards there's not as much strategy
involved but a lot of people in my
family you know Uncle aim became sort of
a euchre guy
um and my cousin Chris and other people
got really into Euchre so you know it
became harder to find sheep's head
players and and a lot of people wanted
to play Euchre instead
um
and I think I kind of fell out of
playing cards as
um time went on you know I I got into
graduate school there wasn't that much
time for doing it there weren't that
many people at Southern Illinois that I
knew who were were into it like uh when
I was in college but it was something I
would do with my family when I would
come back on vacation play some pinochle
play some cribbage
and I haven't done much of that for a
long time other than playing uh the
occasional Rummy 500 with my wife but um
when when we have more time we're
probably going to you know start doing
some other ones uh uh cribbage would be
a lot of fun to do
there's others that perhaps would
require getting involved with other
people and I don't know that we're going
to do that but
I don't know how many hours I spent
playing cards in my youth and 20s but
it's probably quite a lot and a lot of
good memories of just hanging out and
what's cool about cards is you don't
need that much in a lot of cases just a
deck and a table to play on and people
who are interested so there's my story
about playing cards uh been a lot of fun
going down memory lane with this one and
uh you know you might have some
interesting experiences of your own that
you wanna
talk about in the comments or uh you
know shoot your own video about it that
could be kind of cool